it's the greatest era in hip-hop there
are in my opinion there are 10 what I
say are Titan producers that I'm like
these guys are the pillars of what this
music is to me at least you're you're
right I mean you're you're one of them
wow it's wild to be sitting here talking
to you and it's wild for me to be here
you understand like I said my daughter's
sitting here look at her face she's like
what my Dad we're giving you bonus
points I had a rap group for a few years
when I was in college when I was in
college you rhymed well I did I used to
come on give us one Ron
what was your name your rap name
my rap name was example I just could say
ex I used to call myself EX
act time half the time my motto was half
the time my motto was killed a whole
bottle and stopped making sense
like Otto I said it with Paco gang of
foes you a gang of hoes like a brothel
you follow oh